- - L'idéologie semble pouvoir e
dede la vanité a dite Erin O'Toe
dadans une dans un extrait.
L'L'envoyer sur Facebook.Chantal
HéHébert, Alec Castonguay
etet Hélènene Buzzetti. Qu'avezs
cocompris dans cette petite
phphrase?
- - Qu'il aurait eu intérêt t àn
seservir plus souvent aujourd'h.
PaParce que c'était le message e
StStephen Harper a utilisé avant
lului pour essayer, que les
pepetites tailles qu'on gagne à
l'l'intérieur ne se valent pas
grgrand-chose si on se dit
ququalifie disqualifie pour
prprendre le pouvoir.
- - C'est arrivé trop tard. Ale,
ilil a voulu manifestement envor
cece message-là  à c ces députéi
onont voté contre lui.
- - C'est le bon message envoyé,
lele problèmeme c'est pas dans e
memessage que le messager. C'es-
àà-d-dire que la la théorie à la
momode depuis quelques heures ce
quque la droite pure et dure du
cocompte parti conservateur a eu
lala têtete des Erin O'Toole cal
vovoulait recentrer le parti, iy
a a peut-êtrtre un peu devrait -
dededans, qui n'ont pas aimé ce
quque Erin O'Toole a fait, maisn
grgros, c'est lui qui a mal
peperformé qui a donné des
ararguments un peu à t tout le
momonde. Il a cherché à j jouerà
dedeux sur tous les tableaux.
PePendant la course aux électio,
ilil a fait la base, il a essayé
dede parler à t tout le monde, e
avavec les camionneurs, on troue
unune manièrere d'aller parler x
cacamionneurs, on a essayé de
fafaire plaisir à T Temma tout e
momonde qu'il a déplu à t tout e
momonde. Les députés disaient: n
nene peut pas continuer comme ç.
IlIl va y avoir une guerre
ididéologique, pour la course ms
- - non évidemment il n'a pas
réréussi. C'est un message cette
phphrase, un message de
prpragmatisme. Mais lui-mêmeme,a
pepeut-êtrtre pas fait preuve de
prpragmatisme. C'est sûr r qu'il
s's'est effacé et a dit je me
rerecule. Plutôt t que d'expulsa
sésénatrice, dont le crime était
dede dire devant sur le vote de
coconfiance de notre chef, devat
sosont là p pour qu'on règlgle a
ququestion de fois pour toutes.
chchef conservateur aurait peut-
êêtrtre dû l le faire, il faut
sosouligner l'ironie de la
sisituation, le parti conservatr
cécédé connecté sur ses membres,
mamais voit ici, que c'est parti
réréussi à d déloger son chef
seseulement avec la vie de 73
dédéputés. C'est quand mêmeme
paparticulier.
- - C'est la premièrere fois qun
ututilise ce mécanisme Chantal,
esest-ce que vous le trouvez,
efefficace?
- - Tant qu'à f faire couper la
ttêtete, c'est toujours mieux ac
unune épée bien aiguisée. Ce
prprincipe-là, , vous pouvez lee
a a l'avantage d'arriver au même
rérésultat plus rapidement. Quad
lele caucus par la confiance en
soson chef, et là j je vais vous
dodonner quelques exemples.
StStockwell day, des conservates
s's'en vont et quittent le part.
EtEt on arrive au mêmeme résult.
JeJean Chrétien, Paul Martin
ququitte le cabinet et on commee
àà p parler de vote de confianc.
MoMonsieur Chrétien efforçait de
memettre une date sur son
leleadership. John Turner, j'ai
papassé plusieurs mois aller à s
cacaucus pour me demander combin
dede temps ça allait prendre. Àa
fifin, si on a ou non la confiae
cacaucus, c'est mieux que ça se
rrèglgle.
- - Très s bien, on va écouter
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Permettez-moi d'avoir
égégalement une pensée pour mon
cocollègugue, le député de Durh,
dodont je salue la sincérité
etet la rigueur de l'engagement.
ALALAIN RAYES, lieutenant
popolitique pour le Québec, PCC
- - Il y avait de l'insatisfactn
susuite à l la dernièrere élect.
IlIl y a beaucoup de gens
ququi pensaient que Justin Trudu
ététait prêt t à q quitter le
gogouvernail du parti... du pay,
exexcusez-moi, du Canada, mais n
n'n'a pas réussi à a articuler,e
pepense le bon message. Certain,
bobon, étaient insatisfaits
àà c cause des différentes frans
ququ'on a dans notre organisatin
paparce qu'on est une grande
cocoalition. Donc des gens était
ininsatisfaits du message, des
chchangements, je dirais, de cap
ququi avaient été enclenchés aps
lala course à l la chefferie das
cece recentrage du parti, cette
momodernisation. Donc il y avait
dedes frictions et je pense que,
bobon, il a pas réussi à u unir.
(k(klaxons)
PIPIERRE PAUL-HUS, député, PCC,
ChCharl. - Haute-Saint-Charles,c
- - Il devait y avoir
ququelque chose qui se passe,
dodonc les membres ont décidé
cece matin, de façon assez clai,
quque M. O'Toole malheureusement
popouvait pas continuer à d dirr
lele caucus. Maintenant,
cece qu'on vise, c'est de
rerepartir, de continuer d'êtrte
prprêtsts pour la prochaine élen
paparce qu'on n'a pas un caucus
didivisé. On est des gens
ququi s'adorent, qui s'aiment,
mamais qui avaient des divisions
ququi devaient pas êtrtre là..
MaMaintenant, ça va êtrtre régl.
- - Bonne chance vous avait
cocompris. Il y avait des
trtraductions, on n'était pas un
paparti divisé mais il y avait s
tetensions. Je le projet dans
l'l'avenir. Est-ce que c'est
popossible, c'est pas le mêmeme
cocontexte, exposait pour
ququelqu'un de dire voisine le
cacarré dans lequel on va agir.
VeVenez avec moi. On s'en va
babattre les libéraux dans quate
anans.
- - Écoutez, ça dépendra beaucop
dede la durée de cette course au
leleadership. Tout indique que
elelle ne sera pas très s longue
dédéfi, si on veut véritablement
rerecentrer ce parti, il
m'm'apparaît t évident que c'esn
lele recentrant qu'on peut gagnr
unune élection. Pour recentrer s
paparties, il faut augmenter le
nonombre de membres, aller
chchercher des membres à
l'l'extérieur de l'Alberta et de
lala Saskatchewan. Sortir de ce
babassin plus radical dans leurs
opopinions conservatrices.
RaRappelez-vous Jean-Charles,
ququand il a décidé de ne pas li
dadans la course, il a dit je
mamanque de temps pour recruter
ceces orphelins politiques qui
sosont peut-êtrtre plus dans l'e
ququi ne se retrouve pas dans le
paparti conservateur actuel. Je
mamanque de temps pour les
coconvaincre. Enclencher ce
rerecentrage. J'ai un peu peur
ququ'on se retrouve une course
trtrès s court et recel récente
trtrace ne soit pas possible.
- - Puis on est longtemps loin u
popouvoir, Plon il y a des gens
ququi sont prêtsts à f faire des
cocompromis. C'est à l l'époquee
HaHarper, où il a dit qu'une
drdroite d'une servira à r riena
leles conservateur ont perdu les
dedeux dernièreres élections, p-
êêtrtre que des gens vont penser
quque le parti devrait se
momoderniser. Entre autres sur
l'l'environnement, qui est une
ququestion importante. Ce ne sea
papas décemment facile parce que
lala base conservatrice est come
çaça. Elle est facilement
ininfluençable par des coups de
gugueule. Mais il faudra que le
prprochain leader, si vraiment
rerecentrer r la partie sera hoe
avavec la base. Qu'on arrêtete e
fafaire semblant comme le fait
ErErin O'Toole que les Canadiens
vovont voter pour nous quand on
fafait des vidéos pour dire quee
lilibéraux vont mettre fin à t e
foforme de partie. Ça sert
seseulement faire prise plaisirà
lala base, ce n'est pas comme ça
ququ'on attire des nouveaux
élélecteurs. Je suis d'accord ac
HéHélènene, puis la course est
cocourte, plus vadislas faire.
FaFaut que les conservateurs
trtrouvent une manièrere d'y
ararriver.
- - Les deux derniers chefs
coconservateurs sont devenus chs
grgrâcece à l la pluie du tierss
gegens qui ont voté. Qui
s's'identifiait à d des candidae
lala droite religieuse. Et que a
mamajorité des délégués au dernr
cocongrès s du parti conservateà
lala veille de l'élection, ont
rerefusé une résolution qui dist
quque la lutte aux changements
clclimatiques était quelque choe
dadans laquelle il fallait
s's'engager. Alors mettez ces dx
grgroupes l'ensemble, et oui one
gagagnera pas des élections come
çaça, mais des particules à f fe
plplaisir, on n'en a vu d'autre.
OnOn sait où ça mènene. Rappele-
vovous le néo démocrate, quand s
onont congédié Monsieur Mulcair,
onon reprend le contrôlele de la
papartie. Tel que c'était vrai
mamais regardait où ils sont.
- - Je vous écoute, c'est ce mêe
paparti qui n'a pas voulu
rereconnaîtrtre les changements
clclimatiques se donne un chèque
quque vouloir aller dans le sens
dudu vent de ce parti là, , le
popouvoir, va s'éloigner à m mee
qu'ils vont avancer.
- - Une chose qui peut peut-être
jojouer en leur faveur, ça coure
esest courte, je me contredis
pepeut-êtrtre, ces il y a beaucp
momoins de candidats. C'est
ququelque chose qu'on a vu avece
paparti conservateur mais aussi
avavec le parti libéral se
sosouvient. Quand il y a beaucop
dede candidats, il y a évidemmet
unun candidat préféré. Mais c'et
prpréféré là, , ou bien on les ,
ouou bien on les aime pas du to.
IlIls ne sont pas le deuxièmeme
chchoix. Parce que c'est un
sysystèmeme de vote préférentie,
c'c'est préféré la plafonne. C't
dodonc le candidat qui sont
ararrivés troisièmeme ou quatri,
fifinissent par coiffer le
prpréféré.
- - Je ne suis pas en désaccord,
nénéanmoins ce systèmeme a donné
StStéphane Dion. Un moment donn,
lala néanmoins la deuxièmeme foa
dodonné la troisièmemes place
lilibéraux.
- - Qui va plonger, d'après s v.
- - C'est la bonne question, es-
cece qu'on laisse la voie libreà
ququelqu'un en espérant que cete
pepersonne-là s soit le sauveure
pepense à P Poilièvrvre, je ne s
papas certain que ça peut êtrtre
cacandidat qui peut élargir la
babase. Il y y a des gens qui ou
papasser leur tour, en 2007 201,
cecette fois-ci peut-êtrtre qu'l
vovont vouloir êtrtre intéressél
esest très s tôt t pour voir une
ququi va se lancer mais je leur
sosouhaite d'avoir des candidats
dede l'extérieur qui vient le
brbrasser et qui leur amènene
ququelque chose d'intéressant ds
unune course à l la direction.
- - Il n'y aura pas Jason qui et
néné, il n'y aura pas Rona Ambre
ququi a déjà d dit non et tout a
popour dire que dans le moment,
leles deux noms qu'on en pensait
LeLeslie, et Pierre Poilièvrvree
paparti contre l'avortement est
cocontent qu'on soit débarrassée
MoMonsieur où tout le ça laisse
unune idée de l'ambiance.
- - Quand ça fait trois courses
ququ'on en six ans, on épuise le
babassin de candidats potentiel,
lele simple fait que nous troise
sosoir on a de la difficulté à
vovous proposer des noms qui
cicirculent, ça témoigne du dést
ququi est devant eux. Moi ce que
j'j'entends beaucoup chez le
coconservateur c'est que on voit
PoPoilièvrvre comme une rocksta.
J'J'avoue que ça m'étonne
énénormément, ce personnage
popolitique est certes trèss
efefficace mais c'est un teignex
etet harmonieux. Pas
nénécessairement l'image du
coconservatisme moderne un peu
plplus ouvert et moderne. Ça va
pepeut-êtrtre continuer dans une
vovoie qui ne lui sera pas
bébénéfique à l long terme.
- - Ça sera un devoir, à u un mt
susur Ottawa, Hélènene vous estu
ststudio mais on n'entend pas ls
klklaxons ça m'étonne. Le chef e
popolice a dit que le la solutin
dedevait êtrtre politique. Un tr
dede table. Comment vous voyez e
sisiègege qui se poursuit celuii
ararrive à Q Québec.
- - Premièrerement, clairement a
popolice de Ottawa fait une
mamauvaise évaluation. Ils ont
lalaissé des poids-lourds
s's'installer dans des endroits
ststratégiques de la ville de
OtOttawa. Et deuxièmemement, jee
susuis pas sûr r qu'il voulait e
quque la solution devrait
popolitique. Puisque dans le mêe
popoint de presse, il a aussi
paparlé de l'armée de la GRC. Ce
quque j'en conclu ce qu'il ne st
papas quoi faire. Premièrerement
dedeuxièmemement j'imagine que s
auautorités policièreres de la e
dede Québec ont pris des notes.
MaMais aussi sur le Toronto. Et
ququ'ils vont agir possiblement
didifféremment. De la porte
ououverte qu'on a installée. On
lalaisse passer des gens qui
apapprovisionnent des des siège.
EtEt il passe les barrages
popoliciers, à u un moment donnl
vava falloir décider si un siège
nonon
- - on s'en parlait, cette semae
s's'ils vont manquer d'essence.
DeDes poids-lourds ça a des
réréservoirs d'essence assez
grgrand. On peut rouler presque
trtrois semaines avec des
réréservoirs comme ça, donc il e
dedevrait pas venir à c court de
dédécence.
- - Il y a un endroit où ils vot
sese ravitailler on les laisse
papasser. Pour les petits
vévéhicules qui ont besoin mais
popour les grains sont trèss
auautonomes.
- - Pas beaucoup d'équipements
popour remorquer ce genre de
vévéhicule peut-êtrtre qui va fe
rerecours à l l'armée. C'est une
chchose qui font toujours faireu
gogouvernement
- - il n'y a pas un remorqueur i
vava aller remorquer un de ses
cocollègugues. Oubliez ça. Alec,
lalance l'avertissement il dit e
cece n'est pas vrai qu'on va
lalaisser entrer autour du
PaParlement. À Québec.
- - Oui, il peut manifester, c't
unun droit qui est important mas
ilils ne nieront pas à l l'ensee
dede la ville de Québec ce qu'oa
cocomplètetement échappé à O Ot.
LeLes revendications politiques,
auaucune revendication peut être
mimise en place pour le
gogouvernement fédéral. On ne va
papas lever des mesures
sasanitaires. C'est les promesss
ququi décident, la vac